As this year comes to an end, and we think about what politics looks like right now in our country, a good place to understand it is a state political party that made a very bold choice this year.
随着这一年接近尾声，当我们思考当下我国的政治面貌时，了解它的一个好切入点是该州的一个政党，该党在今年做出了一个非常大胆的选择。
[GAVEL STRIKES]
[法槌敲击声]
The convention will come to order.
会议现在开始。
The state is Michigan. This is a meeting that happened in February, where the Michigan Republican Party had to pick a new leader.
这个州是密歇根州。这是一场发生在二月份的会议，当时密歇根州共和党必须选出一位新的领导人。
If you want to return to your seats, you're welcome to. If you don't, that's fine. I know you're going to get up and sprint to vote here in a minute.
如果您想回到座位上，请便。如果不回，也没关系。我知道待会儿大家都要起身冲去投票。
They were at a crossroads. They'd gotten killed in the midterm elections, which was just a few months before this-- creamed. They were further out of power than they'd been in 40 years, with Democrats controlling the State House, the Senate, the Governor's Office, most of the Congressional seats.
他们当时正处于十字路口。仅仅几个月前，他们在中期选举中惨败——可以说是一败涂地。他们掌握的权力比过去40年来任何时候都要少，民主党控制了州众议院、参议院、州长办公室以及大部分国会席位。
And why? Well, a big reason was because the Republicans had all these candidates who were pushing the idea that the presidential election had been stolen. And Michigan voters are not into that. They do not want to elect candidates who are obsessed with the election being stolen, apparently.
为什么会这样？原因很大程度上是因为共和党人推举了大量候选人，这些人极力宣扬总统选举被窃取的观点。而密歇根州的选民对此并不买账。显然，他们不想选举那些沉迷于“选举被窃取”阴谋论的候选人。
So at this meeting in February, the party needed to elect a leader who's going to rebuild and take the party forward. And if you think about it, one logical path they could have taken is, they could have picked somebody who renounced the whole election fraud thing. Right? All the conspiracy theories about voting machines and just all that stuff that Michigan voters are rejecting.
因此，在二月份的这次会议上，该党需要选出一位能够重建并推动政党前进的领导人。如果你仔细想想，他们本可以走的一条合乎逻辑的道路是，选出一位公开反驳选举舞弊说的人。对吧？反驳所有关于投票机的阴谋论，以及那些密歇根州选民正在拒绝的一切。
But there were no candidates like that at all, nobody who said, let's drop all this election fraud stuff. Because a candidate like that would not have a ghost of a chance with the Republicans in this room, who are the ones who actually pick the new party leader. In the last few years, election-fraud stop-the-steal enthusiasts have driven out the regular, old-fashioned conservatives, and even other MAGA-loving Trump enthusiasts.
但当时根本没有这样的候选人，没有人说“让我们放弃这些选举舞弊的陈词滥调吧”。因为这样的候选人根本不可能赢得在场共和党人的支持，而正是这些人决定了新任党魁的人选。在过去的几年里，那些执着于“选举舞弊”和“停止窃取”的狂热分子已经把传统、老派的保守派，甚至其他支持特朗普的MAGA（让美国再次伟大）支持者都赶走了。
Those people have been ousted, if they didn't care enough about election fraud or if they have ties to the old party establishment that this new guard sees as completely corrupt, compromising RINOs. So in the end, at this convention, there were nine candidates. And just to give you a sense of the range of this group, the most traditional Republican of this bunch was a guy named Scott Greenlee.
那些人如果对选举舞弊不够上心，或者与新卫队眼中完全腐败、妥协的“共和党内建制派”（RINO）有联系，就会被排挤出局。所以最终，在那次大会上，共有九名候选人。为了让你了解这一群体的范围，其中最传统的共和党人是一位名叫斯科特·格林利的先生。
And he's somebody who thought like, OK, election fraud is a problem. But he also came with connections to donors, to old-school pre-January 6 Republicans. In fact, Greenlee's an experienced political consultant, which, by the way, in this crowd, is not an asset. He talked to one of the producers on our show, Zoe Chace.
他认为选举舞弊确实是个问题。但他同时与捐赠者以及1月6日之前的共和党老派人士有着联系。事实上，格林利是一位经验丰富的政治顾问，顺便说一句，在这个群体中，这并非加分项。他接受了我们节目制片人佐伊·查斯的采访。
So everyone's telling me that you're the establishment candidate.
大家都说你是建制派候选人。
Oh, my goodness. Well, I get called all the names. I mean, I'm called establishment. I get called a RINO. That's even worse. I've also been called an "America First" guy, because in 2016, I was working extremely hard for President Trump, long before a lot of people were involved in the party.
天哪。好吧，我什么头衔都被安上过。我的意思是，我被称为建制派。我被称为“共和党内建制派”（RINO），这更糟糕。我还被称为“美国优先”的人，因为在2016年，在很多人加入该党之前，我就在为特朗普总统努力工作了。
So that's Scott Greenlee, the most traditional Republican. The least traditional candidate for party chair was a complete political outsider in every way, somebody whose involvement in politics started in 2020 as a poll watcher in Detroit, someone who got famous when she claimed that she saw election fraud with her own eyes. She went on to Steve Bannon's podcast and all kinds of right-wing media, and then ran for Secretary of State.
这就是最传统的共和党人斯科特·格林利。而最不传统的党主席候选人则是一位彻头彻尾的政治门外汉，她对政治的参与始于2020年，当时她是底特律的一名投票观察员，后来因声称亲眼目睹了选举舞弊而声名鹊起。她上了史蒂夫·班农的播客以及各种右翼媒体，随后竞选州务卿。
She's an arresting talker, Black, a Millennial, a devout Christian, named Kristina Karamo. So she tries to become Michigan Secretary of State and was soundly rejected by voters, defeated by 14 percentage points-- again, because Michigan voters are not going for the kind of election-fraud stuff that she was peddling. And she did not concede the race, still hasn't, which is something that the Republican delegates at the state convention loved about her.
她是一位极具煽动力的演说家，黑人，千禧一代，虔诚的基督徒，名叫克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫。她试图竞选密歇根州州务卿，但遭到选民彻底拒绝，以14个百分点的差距落败——再次重申，因为密歇根州的选民并不买她兜售的那种选举舞弊说。她没有承认败选，至今仍未承认，而这正是共和党州代表大会上的代表们最欣赏她的一点。
It's the reason I did not concede after the 2022 election. Why would I concede to a fraudulent process? Conceding to a fraudulent process is an agreement with the fraud, is which I will not do.
这就是我2022年选举后没有承认败选的原因。我为什么要承认一个欺诈性的程序？承认欺诈性程序就是对舞弊的认同，我是绝不会这么做的。
We will grow this party without compromising our values. We're going to be a party that grows like never before. We're going to be a political machine that strikes fear in the heart of Democrats, and we're going to win. Vote Karamo Pego!
我们要壮大这个政党，而不妥协我们的价值观。我们将成为一个前所未有的成长型政党。我们将成为一台让民主党人内心感到恐惧的政治机器，我们将会赢。请投票给卡拉莫和佩戈！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And-- maybe you saw this coming-- Karamo wins. She becomes the head of the Michigan Republican Party, the outsiderist, the grassroots-ist-- not for nothing, the Christianist. And in picking Karamo, Michigan Republicans were saying, basically, what we want as a party is somebody to lead, who, A, believes the election was stolen, and B, has no connection to any establishment political machinery of the past, which is all corrupt.
而且——也许你预料到了——卡拉莫赢了。她成为了密歇根州共和党的主席，她是局外人，是草根派，而且不可否认，她还是基督教派。通过选择卡拉莫，密歇根州共和党人基本上是在说，我们党想要的是一位领袖，第一，相信选举被窃取了，第二，与过去任何腐败的政治机器没有任何瓜葛。
That kind of purity test is something that you see a lot among Republicans right now. In the House of Representatives in Washington, so many political fights are basically between Republicans who don't want to compromise at all, and everybody else. You see this in other Republican state parties in swing states-- Arizona, Colorado, Georgia. But no state party has taken the flying leap off the cliff that the Michigan Republicans have.
这种纯度测试在目前的共和党人中非常普遍。在华盛顿的众议院，许多政治斗争基本上就是那些不想做出任何妥协的共和党人与其他所有人之间的较量。你在其他摇摆州的共和党组织中也看到了这一点——亚利桑那州、科罗拉多州、乔治亚州。但没有哪个州的政党像密歇根州共和党那样从悬崖上飞身跃下。
More than any other state party, they have the least politically connected, furthest-from-the-establishment, most ideological party leader and her followers running things. Among other things, I have to say it is an enormously idealistic act, done by true believers who feel deeply that the only way out of the mess that we're in as a country is a total break with what has come before. And when Karamo won, they were amped.
比起其他任何州的政党，他们拥有最缺乏政治人脉、最远离建制派、意识形态最强烈的党魁及其追随者来掌权。我不得不说，这是一项极其理想主义的行为，由真正的信徒完成，他们深信，我们要想走出国家目前混乱局面的唯一途径，就是与过去彻底决裂。当卡拉莫获胜时，他们非常兴奋。
I am excited. Everything's going to change.
我很兴奋。一切都将改变。
There were tears.
现场有人流泪了。
(CRYING) Oh, my God!
（哭泣）天哪！
Pray for her now. Now, it starts.
现在为她祈祷吧。现在，一切才刚刚开始。
Today, on our program, when a political party takes a leap like this one, throws itself out in an act of faith like this one, in a major swing state, what does that gamble look like? What happens next? Today, we're going to look at how this year unfolded for these true believers.
今天，在我们的节目中，当一个政党采取这样的飞跃，在一个主要的摇摆州进行这样一场信仰赌博时，这种赌注看起来是什么样的？接下来会发生什么？今天，我们将看看这些忠实信徒的一年是如何度过的。
Producer Zoe Chace went many, many times to Michigan throughout this year and has a special up-close and personal look at how all this played out. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
制片人佐伊·查斯在这一年里多次前往密歇根州，对这一切的演变进行了特别的近距离观察。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, The Lonely Island. OK, before we jump any deeper into this, maybe I should take a sec and explain just what a state party actually does. It's basically an organization set up to handle all kinds of boring, practical work that you need to do if you want to win elections. They recruit candidates. They organize meetings. There are these massive get-out-the-vote operations for state elections and for national candidates, too.
第一幕，孤独的岛屿。好吧，在我们深入探讨之前，也许我应该花点时间解释一下州政党到底是做什么的。它基本上是一个组织，负责处理各种无聊但实际的工作，如果你想赢得选举，就必须完成这些工作。他们招募候选人，组织会议。他们为州选举以及全国候选人进行大规模的“动员选民”活动。
And above all else, they raise money to pay for campaigns, buy ads, and do everything else. And the person who raises that money, usually, is the party chair. So to have somebody with no political connections in that job like Kristina Karamo-- that is very unusual. Zoe tells the story from here.
最重要的是，他们筹集资金来支付竞选费用、购买广告，并做所有其他事情。筹集这些资金的人通常是党主席。所以，让像克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫这样没有任何政治背景的人担任这一职位，是非常罕见的。从这里开始，佐伊讲述这个故事。
Now, Kristina Karamo was elected in February, and the party did not pull together behind their new chair. There was a ton of infighting still over the first few months. And the first major test of her leadership, her ability to get things done, came this fall-- the Mackinac Island conference.
克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫是在二月份当选的，但该党并没有团结在新主席身后。在最初的几个月里，内部纷争依然非常严重。她领导能力、执行能力的第一次重大考验出现在今年秋天——麦基诺岛会议。
It's a big, symbolic, fabled event in Michigan politics. Politicians, lobbyists, presidential candidates all make their way up to Northern Michigan and get on a ferry to this island where no cars are allowed-- horse-drawn carriages instead. So the whole place does smell like horse shit, which makes it a perfect setting for a group of politicos.
这是密歇根政治中一个重大的、象征性的、传说中的活动。政客、说客、总统候选人都前往密歇根州北部，乘坐渡轮前往这个禁止汽车通行的岛屿——岛上只有马车。所以整个地方都弥漫着马粪味，这使得它成为政客们聚会的完美场所。
They hobnob. They gossip. They make deals. They raise money. And the test for Kristina was, with all the old-school Republicans she and her followers have ejected from the party, could she raise enough money to even hold the conference? Would it even happen?
他们社交，流言蜚语，达成交易，筹集资金。对克里斯蒂娜的考验是，既然她和她的追随者已经把所有老派共和党人都赶出了党，她还能筹集到足够的资金来举办这次会议吗？这会发生吗？
Raising money is probably the most important thing the state party chair does, and Kristina has no fundraising background. Over the last 10 years, the list of reported jobs she's done are the scraping-by kind-- salesclerk, trivia host, substitute teacher, adjunct community college instructor. She made a Christian podcast.
筹款可能是州党主席最重要的工作，而克里斯蒂娜没有任何筹款经验。在过去十年中，她做过的工作都是勉强维持生计的那种——售货员、琐事竞赛主持人、代课老师、社区学院兼职讲师。她还制作过一个基督教播客。
Her plan to fund the party was to get donations from small Republican businesses who have supposedly been sitting on the sidelines because they didn't think the party was conservative enough. But that never seemed to get off the ground. And for months before Mackinac, there were rumors like, how would she ever come up with the cash for this big showboaty affair?
她资助该党的计划是向那些一直袖手旁观的小型共和党企业募捐，因为他们认为该党不够保守。但这似乎从未起步。在麦基诺会议之前的几个月里，就有传言说，她怎么可能为这种大型炫耀性的活动筹集到现金呢？
To get a read on those rumors, I checked in now and then with Jon Smith. He's the perfect person to go to, because he totally epitomizes what the Michigan GOP has become. He's an unabashed conspiracy theorist.
为了了解这些传闻，我不时与乔恩·史密斯交流。他是最合适的对象，因为他完全体现了密歇根共和党现在的样子。他是一个毫无顾忌的阴谋论者。
He started in state politics around 2020. He chartered two buses to get to January 6-- didn't go inside the Capitol, he says. And he and others stop-the-steal-ers took over their local county parties. Jon's on the state committee now. And he was like, I doubt Kristina raised enough money to pull off Mackinac.
他大约在2020年开始参与州政治。他包了两辆大巴前往1月6日的集会——他说他没有进入国会大厦内部。他和“停止窃取”运动的其他成员接管了当地的县党部。乔恩现在是州委员会成员。他说，他怀疑克里斯蒂娜筹集到的钱是否足以支撑麦基诺会议。
I think they're lying to people about speakers and stuff. They don't have a way to pay for them, I don't think. But I think-- you know that documentary with that guy that did that concert on the island-- "Fry"? I think that's what they're doing here.
我认为他们在演讲者之类的东西上对人们撒谎。我不认为他们有钱支付他们的费用。但我认为——你知道那个在岛上举办音乐会的家伙的纪录片吗？“Fyre音乐节”？我想他们在这里做的就是那件事。
[LAUGHS] The Fyre Festival.
[笑声] Fyre音乐节。
But it's MIGOP, you know. That's what District 9 chair is telling me.
但这可是密歇根共和党（MIGOP），你知道的。这就是第9区主席告诉我的。
Literally, in the Fyre Festival documentary, people show up in the Bahamas, and instead of Blink 182 and the Instagram models they were promised, there is no music, no food, no water, and soggy FEMA tents. What we all find at Mackinac isn't quite that desperate.
实际上，在Fyre音乐节的纪录片中，人们出现在巴哈马，结果承诺的Blink 182乐队和Instagram模特都没来，没有音乐，没有食物，没有水，只有潮湿的联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）帐篷。我们在麦基诺所看到的并没有那么绝望。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏声]
When I got up to the Grand Hotel, there was definitely a Republican conference taking place, with Trump hats and red-white-and-blue sparkly pins, as promised. And a grand piano playing a song about how anything is possible if only you believe.
当我到达大酒店时，确实正在举行共和党会议，正如承诺的那样，有特朗普的帽子和红白蓝闪亮的徽章。还有一架大钢琴正在演奏一首关于“只要你相信，一切皆有可能”的歌。
But apparently, this year was really different from past years. At night, I was wandering with a couple attendees, including one of the younger vice chairs, Hassan Nehme, in a suit and a low founding-fathers-y ponytail. We were headed upstairs in an elevator, looking for the Mackinac parties, which I'd heard were legendary.
但显然，今年与往年大不相同。晚上，我和几位与会者闲逛，其中包括一位较年轻的副主席哈桑·内梅，他穿着西装，留着低马尾。我们坐电梯上楼，寻找麦基诺派对，我听说那些派对是传奇般的。
Oh, you haven't been to one of these before?
哦，你以前没参加过这种聚会吗？
No.
没有。
Oh, yeah, it's very fun.
哦，是的，非常有趣。
This is your first time in Mackinac.
这是你第一次来麦基诺。
Oh, yeah, this is very-- it's like-- imagine going to the mall, and there's, like, one store open. This is how this weekend feels to me.
哦，是的，这非常——就像——想象一下去商场，结果只有一家店开门。这就是这个周末给我的感觉。
In what way? How is it like one store--
怎么讲？怎么像只有一家店开门？
'Cause last time you walk on the porch, there's, like, 800 people, and now, there's, like, nobody--
因为上次你走在门廊上，有大约800人，现在，几乎没人——
Yeah.
是的。
--in every event.
——在每个活动中。
Yeah. Last time, there were around 2,000 attendees. This year, the best guess I saw was 800 at the very most. Last time, Ted Cruz was a keynote speaker. A big name national Republican. This time? QAnon proponent Jim Caviezel, who made the sleeper summer hit movie about child sex trafficking, Sound of Freedom. He also played Jesus in the Passion of the Christ.
是的。上次大约有2000名与会者。今年，我看到的最好估计最多也就800人。上次，泰德·克鲁兹是主题演讲人。一位全国知名共和党人。这次呢？QAnon支持者吉姆·卡维泽，他制作了那个关于儿童性贩运的夏季爆款电影《自由之声》。他还曾在《耶稣受难记》中饰演耶稣。
Out on the colossal porch at one point, I talked to another state committee member who was upset about how things seemed to be going.
有一次在巨大的门廊上，我和另一位州委员会成员谈话，她对事情的进展感到不安。
Well, it's not exactly what we were hoping or anticipating.
嗯，这并不完全是我们所希望或预期的。
Mark Forton is one of those who wanted a complete break with how it used to be. And how it used to be was that the head of the party was a super-rich Michigan guy, real estate mogul Ron Weiser. In the last few years, the party yearly budget has been something like $20 million, a chunk of which came directly from Weiser, and mostly one other rich family in Michigan-- the Devoses.
马克·福顿是那些想要彻底决裂、摆脱过去运作方式的人之一。过去，该党的负责人是一位超级富有的密歇根人，房地产大亨罗恩·怀泽。过去几年，党每年的预算大约是2000万美元，其中一部分直接来自怀泽，大部分来自密歇根州的另一个富裕家庭——德沃斯家族。
We knew that if the grassroots took over the state party, that the big shooters would go. Not all of them, but we knew the DeVos family would go and Mr. Weiser would go. They're all globalist. They're all part of the same great, big mess that Michigan's in-- you know, bringing in the Chinese, battery factories. So I mean, we know they're globalists.
我们知道，如果基层接管了州政党，那些大人物就会离开。不是所有人，但我们知道德沃斯家族会走，怀泽先生也会走。他们都是全球主义者。他们都是密歇根州目前陷入的大泥潭的一部分——你知道，引进中国人，建电池厂。所以我的意思是，我们知道他们是全球主义者。
And then, Mark spins out the first of the many times I will hear the theory that Kristina is a globalist plant, and that the reason things are going so badly is that the establishment planned it this way, from the beginning of her rise to power.
然后，马克提出了我将听到的无数次关于“克里斯蒂娜是全球主义者的卧底”这一理论，并且事情变得如此糟糕是因为建制派从她崛起的最初起就预谋好了。
They knew the grassroots had had enough and they're going to take over this party. They knew it then. Now, the question is, are these globalist types-- are they going to sit by and take it? Or are they going to start planning for when the grassroots take over-- what do we do next? They're after Michigan. There's no doubt.
他们知道基层受够了，要接管这个政党。他们当时就知道。现在的问题是，这些全球主义者类型的人——他们会袖手旁观吗？还是他们会开始策划当基层接管时——我们接下来该怎么做？他们冲着密歇根州来的。毫无疑问。
But she's like the most anti-globalist of them all. She's the anti-globalistest.
但她是最反全球主义的人之一。她是反全球主义者中的反全球主义者。
Oh, I know. I'm not accusing her. I'm saying, but who's pulling the strings? Who-- I just don't know what to think. I'm telling you things that-- you're asking me what's on my mind.
哦，我知道。我不是在指责她。我说的是，谁在幕后操纵？谁——我只是不知道该怎么想。我是在告诉你——你问我心里在想什么。
You're asking me what I'm concerned about. And none of them are facts. But my gosh, you look at all this crap going on, and you can't come up with a decent answer. I just don't know. I just-- I'm trying to find out.
你问我担心什么。这些都不是事实。但是天哪，看看所有这些发生的烂事，你却给不出一个体面的答案。我只是不知道。我只是——我正在努力找出真相。
That's not the only conspiracy theory I hear about Kristina. In the hallway, I run into someone whose conspiracy theory is on a parallel track, but going the other way-- Braden Giacobazzi, kind of a frantic little dude. He's a major Kristina supporter, a chair on one of her committees.
关于克里斯蒂娜的阴谋论不仅仅是这一个。在走廊里，我遇到了一个人，他的阴谋论处于平行轨道，但方向相反——布雷登·贾科巴齐，一个有点疯狂的家伙。他是克里斯蒂娜的主要支持者，她委员会的主席之一。
Braden says it's not Kristina who's the globalist plant. Instead, there are secret operatives within the party who are trying to take her out. They're doing it by starting all these rumors. He and his friend, Ken Beyer, another Karamo loyalist, told me about a few.
布雷登说，克里斯蒂娜不是全球主义者的卧底。相反，党内有秘密特工正试图搞垮她。他们通过散布所有这些谣言来做到这一点。他和他的朋友肯·拜尔，另一位卡拉莫的忠实拥护者，告诉了我几个。
Like, today, they came up with a rumor that Karamo is going to retire. It's, like, the most absurd nonsense.
比如，今天他们编造了一个谣言，说卡拉莫要退休了。这简直是极其荒谬的胡说八道。
I saw that on Twitter.
我在推特上看到了。
But why even start that rumor? What is that?
但为什么要散布这种谣言？那是什么？
They lied, because they didn't want people to show up and pack the house. That's why they didn't--
他们撒谎，因为他们不想让人出现，不想让会场爆满。这就是为什么他们不——
That's exactly what they did.
他们正是这么做的。
So they-- I mean, we've been fighting this for a while, and all they do is lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, lie.
所以他们——我的意思是，我们已经和这种行为斗争了一段时间，他们所做的就是撒谎，撒谎，撒谎，撒谎，撒谎，撒谎，撒谎。
And they'll make up the most absurd rumors, because they know if they do that, it'll make-- it will try to discredit this event, try to discredit the administration, and try to discredit, basically, all of the MIGOP.
他们会编造最荒谬的谣言，因为他们知道如果他们这样做，就会——就会试图抹黑这次活动，试图抹黑行政部门，并试图抹黑整个密歇根共和党。
Why would they want to do that?
他们为什么要那样做？
People want power. There's an old saying. I don't know where it comes from. But some people would rather rule over ashes than allow somebody to beat them.
人们想要权力。有一句古老的格言。我不知道它来自哪里。但有些人宁愿统治废墟，也不愿让别人打败他们。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Right?
对吧？
--something Kristina Karamo said.
——克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫说过的话。
That's absolutely-- oh, well, there you go. I think it's from Game of Thrones.
那是绝对的——哦，好吧，这就是了。我想它出自《权力的游戏》。
The actual business at Mackinac, the meeting of party leaders, was a showdown between Kristina supporters and Kristina skeptics about party finances. This was a closed meeting, but I got a tape. Kristina's team claimed they'd raised $650,000. The skeptics demanded they open up the books and prove it. Toward the end of the meeting, Kristina went to the podium to defend herself.
在麦基诺的实际事务，即党内领袖会议上，克里斯蒂娜的支持者与怀疑者之间就党的财政问题进行了决战。这是一次闭门会议，但我录了音。克里斯蒂娜的团队声称他们筹集了65万美元。怀疑者要求他们公开账目以证明这一点。会议快结束时，克里斯蒂娜走到讲台上为自己辩护。
As far as the financial health of the party, the party is not going bankrupt. It's not. But-- but-- but I mean, what-- if you received the treasurer report, unless you think the treasurer is lying to you-- now, I will make a comment about a lot of the people who aren't giving. Is it because they don't like or feel we're going to bankrupt or because they don't like the philosophical direction of the party?
就党的财务健康状况而言，该党不会破产。不会的。但是——但是——但是我的意思是，如果你们收到了财务报表，除非你们认为财务主管在对你们撒谎——现在，我要对许多没有捐款的人发表评论。是因为他们不喜欢或者觉得我们要破产，还是因为他们不喜欢该党的哲学方向？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That's what's really going on here.
这才是这里真正发生的事情。
At the end of the day, Kristina's team does not agree to, quote unquote, "open the books," show them the party finances. And everyone trudges down to the boats, frustrated with each other, dodging the piles of fresh horse shit.
到最后，克里斯蒂娜的团队不同意所谓“公开账目”，不愿展示党的财务状况。每个人都沮丧地走向船只，躲避着成堆的新鲜马粪。
Act Two, Another Purity Test. Just a few days after the conference ended, there was something else, that really has nothing to do with money, that came up about Kristina's GOP-- about who's welcome inside this party. It was an email anonymously penned by a guy who called himself Paul Revere.
第二幕，又一次纯度测试。在会议结束后仅几天，又发生了一件事，与钱无关，但与克里斯蒂娜的共和党有关——关于谁受欢迎进入这个党。这是一封由一个自称“保罗·里维尔”的人匿名撰写的电子邮件。
And the gist was, an Islamic takeover of America is happening. Homicidal Islamic terrorists are becoming entrenched and infecting our whole country. It concluded, "To paraphrase Sir Winston Churchill, Islam in a man is as dangerous as rabies in a dog."
要点是，一场伊斯兰对美国的接管正在发生。杀人成性的伊斯兰恐怖分子正在扎根并感染我们整个国家。最后结论是，“引用温斯顿·丘吉尔爵士的话，人身上的伊斯兰教就像狗身上的狂犬病一样危险。”
This email was sent out to district chairs and vice chairs of the state party. Three of the vice chairs are Muslim, and two of them replied all, because they felt attacked by the anonymous email. One of them was Hassan Nehme, the guy I was in the elevator with at Mackinac. Here's what he wrote.
这封电子邮件发送给了该州党的区主席和副主席。其中三位副主席是穆斯林，两位回复了所有人，因为他们觉得被那封匿名邮件攻击了。其中一位是哈桑·内梅，我在麦基诺电梯里遇到的那个家伙。这是他写的。
"Good evening, Kristina. This email was sent out to the Republican leadership, every elected member, and all the district chairs. Conveniently, you were not added, So I decided to forward it over. I noticed that others have forwarded it to you, so I was eagerly awaiting a response from you."
“晚上好，克里斯蒂娜。这封邮件发送给了共和党领导层、每一位当选成员和所有区主席。方便的是，你没有被添加进去，所以我决定转发给你。我注意到其他人已经转发给你了，所以我一直在焦急地等待你的回应。”
Hassan wants her to condemn it publicly. He continues, "I took the liberty of reaching out to my contacts at Fox, ABC, and a couple of the Detroit news outlets today, with the hopes that you would join the Muslim vice-chairs to respond to this. We need to ensure our constituents understand that the party will not stand for this and that our party stands for the Constitution, which defends the freedom of religion.
哈桑希望她能公开谴责这一点。他继续说，“我今天冒昧联系了我在福克斯新闻、ABC新闻以及底特律几家新闻媒体的联系人，希望你能加入穆斯林副主席的行列做出回应。我们需要确保我们的选民明白，该党不会容忍这种行为，而且我们的党捍卫宪法，捍卫宗教自由。
So you either join us on air and we all play nice and show what our party stands for, or we go on there and talk about how you have sidelined us and that you have yet to condemn any of this rhetoric." Hassan says he never heard back from Kristina.
所以，要么你加入我们一起上节目，我们大家表现得和善一点，展示我们党所代表的东西，要么我们自己去谈谈你如何将我们边缘化，以及你如何尚未谴责任何这些言论。”哈桑说他再也没有收到克里斯蒂娜的回复。
I went to talk with Hassan and his cousin Ali about their place in the party, if there even is a place in this party for them under Karamo. These are idealistic Republicans who agree with her and what she stands for. They were like exactly what you might think the Republican Party would want-- young Muslim guys in the Democratic stronghold of Dearborn, genuinely excited about the potential of bringing Arab Americans into the Republican Party.
我和哈桑以及他的表弟阿里谈了谈他们在党内的地位，如果在卡拉莫领导下这个党里还有他们的一席之地的话。这些是理想主义的共和党人，他们同意她和她所代表的东西。他们看起来就像你可能认为共和党会想要的那种人——在迪尔伯恩这个民主党大本营的年轻穆斯林小伙子，对将阿拉伯裔美国人带入共和党充满热情。
I met them at a business they own, a print shop in a cellar, no cell phone service, no windows, fluorescent lights, concrete walls, and their dog Pickles. Where we sat in the back was a big sign up for Hassan's election. He ran for the US House a year ago, for Rashida Tlaib's seat. Or he tried.
我在他们拥有的一家地下室印刷厂见到了他们，没有手机信号，没有窗户，荧光灯，混凝土墙，还有他们的狗“泡菜”。我们坐在后排，上面挂着一块哈桑竞选的牌子。他一年前竞选过美国众议院，是为了拉希达·特莱布的席位。或者说他尝试过。
I didn't even make it past the primaries. It was-- I spent my entire campaign trying to prove to the Republicans that I was a Republican because of my faith, so it was very fun.
我甚至没能通过初选。我花了整个竞选过程试图向共和党人证明，因为我的信仰，我是一个共和党人，所以这很有趣。
What is that-- what was that like?
那是怎么回事——那是什么样的？
It was very interesting. It was the first time my life I sat in a meeting where they're talking about anti-Sharia law. And I'm a Muslim. I didn't know what Sharia law was.
非常有趣。这是我第一次坐在一个会议室里，他们正在讨论反伊斯兰教法。而我是一个穆斯林。我甚至不知道伊斯兰教法是什么。
So I'm just sitting there listening to these people talk things about my faith that I don't even believe, and how we're getting into politics to take it all over and corrupt society. And I'm just sitting there like-- I'm a politician, running for Congress, sitting in the audience, listening to this. And it happened a lot. It happened a lot. It's kind of what led to running for the vice-chair roles-- was kind of, hey, this is not right.
所以我只是坐在那里，听着这些人谈论着我不相信的关于我信仰的事情，以及我们是如何进入政治领域来接管一切并腐蚀社会的。我只是坐在那里，就像——我是一个政治候选人，竞选国会议员，坐在观众席上，听着这一切。这种情况经常发生。经常发生。这在某种程度上导致了我去竞选副主席职位——主要是，嘿，这不对。
The more people seem to doubt them, the more these guys wanted to prove that they belonged. Like, we're family-values conservatives, too. We're concerned about what our kids are learning in schools, too. We think there's big election fraud, too. We belong here so much, we actually should be in the leadership of the party.
越是有人怀疑他们，这群人就越想证明他们属于这里。就像，我们也是家庭价值保守派。我们也很关心我们的孩子在学校学什么。我们也认为存在严重的选举舞弊。我们非常属于这里，实际上我们应该进入党的领导层。
Hassan ran for coalitions vice chair, Ali ran for administrative vice chair. No one ran against them. Still, on the day of the leadership race, when Karamo was elected chair, one of the people in their own district tried to sabotage them.
哈桑竞选联盟副主席，阿里竞选行政副主席。没有人与他们竞争。尽管如此，在卡拉莫当选主席的领导权竞选当天，他们自己选区里的一些人试图破坏他们。
They wanted to open the floor to nominations, because they couldn't let the Muslims run unopposed. And there was ladies out of Macomb-- and this was, like-- a lot of people have on record, saying, like, they were going around saying those exact quotes.
他们想要开放提名，因为他们不能让穆斯林没有对手。而且马科姆县有几位女士——这一点很多人都有记录，她们到处散布这些确切的言论。
Yeah, isn't that crazy?
是的，那不是很疯狂吗？
That's Ali, Hassan's cousin, admin vice chair. He's more relaxed than Hassan, tipped back in his seat. He says things started to get weird right before the vote.
那是阿里，哈桑的表弟，行政副主席。他比哈桑更放松，靠在椅子上。他说投票前事情开始变得奇怪。
While right before that, some lady came up to us. I forgot her name, but she was talking to us like, hey, do you take Jesus Christ as your Lord and Savior? And we're like, bro, what the-- that's so off.
投票前，一位女士走过来找我们。我忘了她的名字，但她对我们说，嘿，你接受耶稣基督作为你的主和救主吗？我们就像，兄弟，这是什么——太离谱了。
That's out of pocket, first of all. Second of all, you're asking someone that doesn't believe in that if they want to believe in it now. Like, you didn't even build up to it.
首先，这不礼貌。其次，你是在问一个不相信这一点的人，他们现在想相信吗？就像，你甚至没有铺垫。
This is just like, you walked onto the convention floor--
就像是你走上大会现场——
I wouldn't hire her if I had a sales company.
如果我有销售公司，我不会雇她。
She came up to where our districts are. We were going to our district's areas. And it was just rude, the way--
她走到我们选区的区域。我们当时正走向我们选区的区域。那太粗鲁了，那种方式——
Yeah, it was so rude.
是的，太粗鲁了。
And no, but we had the conversation-- I had the conversation with her gladly. And then actually, after the convention, I met up with her, and we had another conversation for, like, an hour. I'm more than willing to entertain that conversation, how our faiths are very similar or not.
不，但我们确实进行了谈话——我很高兴地和她进行了谈话。实际上，大会结束后，我遇到了她，我们又谈了一个小时。我非常愿意进行那种谈话，关于我们的信仰是非常相似还是不相似。
I'm not an enemy. We are not enemies, the way the media perceives it. But I'll have that conversation all day, but--
我不是敌人。我们不是媒体所理解的那种敌人。但我可以整天进行那种谈话，但是——
Wait, tell the story, though. Because I feel like I'm missing the beginning of the story. So what happened?
等等，讲讲那个故事吧。因为我觉得我错过了故事的开头。所以发生了什么？
So we were at convention, doing our rounds. This is the day of the election, so we're talking to everybody, letting them know, hey, this is our plan. This is what we're doing. We're introducing ourselves. You know, yada, yada.
当时我们在大会现场，到处转。那是选举当天，所以我们和每个人谈话，告诉他们，嘿，这是我们的计划。这是我们要做的。我们在介绍自己。你知道，云云。
And somebody goes up there during new business and wants to put it out there, like hey, we want to open the floor to have them-- or change bylaws so we could put people up against them. And everybody starts going crazy. And--
然后有人在处理新事务时走上前去，想要把它提出来，就像嘿，我们想要开放现场提名，或者修改章程，这样我们就能找人跟他们竞争。每个人都开始变得疯狂。然后——
Did they say specifically, like, because they're Muslim?
他们是否有明确说，是因为他们是穆斯林？
Yeah, they were passing out pamphlets. We learned after the fact, that there were pamphlets being passed out by these ladies. Like, how are you going to let their voices-- and then--
是的，他们在散发小册子。我们后来才知道，这些女士在散发小册子。就像，你怎么能让他们的声音——然后——
Just to be clear, someone stood up during convention to make a motion that someone could declare their candidacy right then, to stop these Muslims from becoming leaders of the party. Still, it didn't pass, and these guys ended up as vice chairs. They were excited. Like, hey, what's my budget line? What's the credentials to start emailing people as official state party representatives?
为了清楚起见，有人在大会期间起立提出动议，要求可以立即宣布候选人资格，以阻止这些穆斯林成为党的领导人。尽管如此，动议没有通过，这些家伙最终成为了副主席。他们很兴奋。就像，嘿，我的预算是多少？作为正式的州党代表开始发邮件的证书是什么？
Let's drive around, set up meetings, do whatever it is this new experimental group of people wants to do, to reach out to people. But there were no leadership team meetings. They say no one called them to tell them, here's what we want you to do and how to do it, and that they were the ones, Hassan and Ali, who set up the first leadership meeting for vice chairs all across the state. Kristina didn't show up to it.
让我们到处开车，安排会议，做这群新的实验性团体想做的任何事情，去接触人们。但没有领导团队会议。他们说没有人叫他们告诉他们，我们想让你做什么，怎么做，而且是哈桑和阿里，是他们为全州范围内的副主席安排了第一次领导会议。克里斯蒂娜没有出席。
Then, there was the whole Mackinac situation. The guys wanted to help plan it, and the bylaws say that the admin vice chair-- that's Ali-- is supposed to play a big role in planning it. But they say no one would communicate with them about it. Finally, they ended up at a meeting in Lansing with Kristina and some of her team, where they came away with the message, we don't want people like you leading things with this party.
然后，还有整个麦基诺的情况。小伙子们想帮忙策划，章程规定行政副主席——也就是阿里——应该在策划中发挥重要作用。但他们说没有人愿意和他们沟通。最后，他们最终在兰辛与克里斯蒂娜和她的一些团队开了个会，在那里他们得到的结论是，我们不希望像你们这样的人在党内领导事务。
In Hassan and Ali's telling, this is how the meeting went. Hassan was like, why aren't you advertising what a diverse leadership we are? You're Black. You have three Arab-Muslim vice chairs. You have an Indian-American district chair. You should be talking about that.
用哈桑和阿里的话说，会议是这样进行的。哈桑说，为什么你不宣传我们是一个多么多元化的领导层？你是黑人。你有三位阿拉伯裔穆斯林副主席。你有一位印度裔美国区主席。你应该谈论这个。
Yeah, it all goes back to, it's a Judeo-Christian movement, and somehow, my faith doesn't play a role in that.
是的，这又回到了起点，这是一个犹太-基督教运动，不知何故，我的信仰在其中没有发挥任何作用。
This was said to you explicitly?
这是明确对你说的吗？
Well, yeah, along those lines. You want exact-- but yes, along those lines, it's like, it's the Judeo-Christian values, and we're not a part of this plan.
嗯，是的，沿着这些思路。你想要确切的——但是是的，沿着这些思路，就像，这是犹太-基督教价值观，而我们不是这个计划的一部分。
How did it make you feel?
这让你感觉如何？
I don't know. I'm used to it. I don't care. I'm still going to do what I think is right.
我不知道。我习惯了。我不在乎。我仍然会做我认为正确的事情。
You must have been upset, hurt.
你一定很沮丧，受伤。
It just bothers you, because it's not like-- the Federalist Papers and the Anti-Federalist Papers were some of the best things I've ever read in my life, and those conversations that took place. And then, you deal with this type of rhetoric, and you're like, if we're truly talking about the founding fathers, the founding fathers did all of this so there's freedom of religion, so--
这只是困扰你，因为这并不像——《联邦党人文集》和《反联邦党人文集》是我一生中读过的最好的东西，还有那些发生的对话。然后，你处理这种言论，你会觉得，如果我们真的在谈论开国元勋，开国元勋做这一切都是为了宗教自由，所以——
Ali had stepped out and walks back into the room at this point.
阿里这时走出了房间，又走了回来。
What did you say, Hassan? Let me see--
你说什么，哈桑？让我看看——
No, we were talking about the diversity and why we're not playing it and playing the three--
不，我们是在谈论多元化，以及为什么我们不玩这个，不玩那三个——
Oh, yeah, yeah. She said--
哦，是的，是的。她说——
"She," Kristina.
“她”，克里斯蒂娜。
The country wasn't founded off of Muslim beliefs. It was founded off of Judeo-Christian beliefs. And that's a fact. You can look that up for yourself." And then, I'm like, yeah, we understand that, but like, let's be more inclusive and word it differently, so everyone's included, you know. Because we got the most amount of Muslims in America right in your-- like, right there, you know?
“国家不是建立在穆斯林信仰基础上的。它是建立在犹太-基督教信仰基础上的。这是一个事实。你可以自己查一下。”然后，我就说，是的，我们理解这一点，但是，让我们更具包容性，换个说法，这样每个人都包括在内，你知道的。因为我们有美国最多的穆斯林就在你的——就在那里，你知道的？
I don't want to talk about what was said in that conversation, like exactly what was said.
我不想谈论那次谈话中说了什么，比如确切说了什么。
Yeah, don't-- be nice about everything.
是的，别——对一切都客气点。
Hassan starts to get annoyed, staring down the table at Ali.
哈桑开始变得恼火，盯着桌子对面的阿里。
But yeah, she was--
但是的，她是——
No, I'm genuinely-- we're trying to keep our Republican Party together, and I'm not-- this just makes it a lot more--
不，我真的很——我们正在努力保持我们的共和党团结在一起，我不是——这只是让它变得更加——
Hey, the truth is the truth, man. Once you say something, you say it.
嘿，事实就是事实，伙计。一旦你说出什么，你就说了。
I'm not against the truth, man. I'm not against the truth. It's just, this would cause much more problems when it comes out-- the wording that was used-- it plays the rhetoric-- then hey, we were just told that you guys are not a part of the plan.
我并不反对事实，伙计。我并不反对事实。只是，当它传出来时，这会引起更多的问题——所用的措辞——它迎合了那种言论——然后嘿，我们刚才被告知你们不是计划的一部分。
Well, she didn't say that.
好吧，她没说那个。
Basically, they felt like at the meeting in Lansing, that they were being subjected to a different purity test-- not one about who was grassroots enough, but about whether anybody but Christians had a place in Kristina Karamo's party. I talked to Kristina about this, and she categorically denied this version of events. She says, of course, there's a place for Muslims in her leadership, and she says she did try to include Hassan and Ali, but they were unresponsive.
基本上，他们觉得在兰辛的会议上，他们正受到另一场纯度测试——不是关于谁足够草根，而是关于除了基督徒之外的任何人是否在克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫的党内有一席之地。我和克里斯蒂娜谈过这件事，她断然否认了这种说法。她说，当然，穆斯林在她的领导层中有一席之地，她说她确实试图包括哈桑和阿里，但他们没有回应。
Hassan shared screenshots with me that showed him reaching out to her about Mackinac specifically and getting brushed off. In any case, by the time they got to Mackinac, which they had played no part in putting together, Hassan and Ali were feeling salty.
哈桑分享了截图给我，显示他专门联系她关于麦基诺的事情，却被冷落了。无论如何，当他们到达麦基诺时，他们没有参与任何筹备工作，哈桑和阿里感到很委屈。
We got there, and we didn't even-- they didn't even make us name tags. And that was a statement. Like, you already know--
我们到了那里，他们甚至没有——他们甚至没有给我们做名牌。那是一个声明。就像，你已经知道——
That was so mean.
那太刻薄了。
That was offensive. And they got mad when we asked, where's our name tags? Like, hey, guys, we don't have name tags, and they're like, here, and then they gave us, like-- whatever. At that point, I'm not going to lie, I was kind of being petty.
那太冒犯了。而且当我们问，我们的名牌在哪里时，他们还生气了。就像，嘿，伙计们，我们没有名牌，他们就像，给，然后他们给了我们，像——随便是谁。在那一点上，我不会撒谎，我有点小心眼了。
They gave us, like, General Admission, and I'm like, hey, we're vice chairs. Like, no, no, no. Can I get a VIP one? Like, what are you guys doing?
他们给了我们，像，普通入场证，我说，嘿，我们是副主席。就像，不，不，不。我能拿到VIP的吗？就像，你们在做什么？
But yeah, we were not involved. All I did there to help was, during the meeting on Sunday, the lights guy asked me if he could head out, so I told him, yeah, go ahead, leave. [LAUGHS]
但是的，我们没有参与。我在那里帮忙做的唯一一件事是，在周日的会议上，灯光师问我他是否可以先走，所以我告诉他，是的，去吧，走吧。[笑声]
Nice.
不错。
We're still talking when Hassan's phone rings. It's Jon Smith, the guy I always talk to about what's happening in the party-- the Fyre Festival guy. He's got news.
我们还在谈话时，哈桑的手机响了。是乔恩·史密斯，我总是和他谈论党内正在发生的事情的那个人——那个“Fyre音乐节”家伙。他有消息。
Hey, did you guys see McCarthy today?
嘿，你们今天看麦卡锡的新闻了吗？
No, I've been doing a six-hour-long interview.
没有，我一直在做一个六小时长的采访。
Did you see-- did you see, Zoe?
你看到了吗——你看到了吗，佐伊？
No, I've been in the interview, too.
没有，我也一直在采访中。
So, so Matt Gaetz led the charge, and they got McCarthy out and voted with the Democrats.
所以，所以马特·盖茨牵头，他们把麦卡锡赶下台了，还和民主党人投票。
Oh, they got him out?
哦，他们把他赶下台了？
He's out?
他下台了？
First time in history.
历史上第一次。
Relatable to these new Michigan Republicans, who have a habit of overthrowing. First, they overthrew their own establishment. Now, they're having buyer's remorse over the bet they made on Kristina, wondering if they should try to remove her, too.
与这些新的密歇根共和党人相关，他们有推翻政权的习惯。首先，他们推翻了自己的建制派。现在，他们对自己在克里斯蒂娜身上下的赌注感到后悔，想知道他们是否也应该尝试罢免她。
I mean, there's no good time to remove a leadership role. But if it's out of spite, then I don't like it. If it's out of principle and it's true to what they're saying, then fuck it, go for it.
我的意思是，没有罢免领导角色的好时机。但如果是出于恶意，那我不喜欢。如果它是出于原则，并且忠实于他们所说的，那去他的，就这么干吧。
You know, I kind of agree with Jon there. Like, if everything is really as corrupt as they're saying and we get more solid evidence, and everything's spread to the light and it looks like what it is, then I don't see these efforts as being misguided.
你知道，我有点同意乔恩的观点。就像，如果一切真的像他们说的那样腐败，我们有了更多确凿的证据，一切都大白于天下，看起来就是那样，那么我不觉得这些努力是被误导的。
Are you talking about Kristina now or are you still talking about McCarthy?
你现在是在谈论克里斯蒂娜还是还在谈论麦卡锡？
I was ordering pizza, so I just jumped in, pretending I know what we were talking about, to be honest. So were we talking about Kristina or McCarthy right now?
我刚才在订披萨，所以我就跳进来了，假装我知道我们在谈什么，说实话。所以我们现在是在谈论克里斯蒂娜还是麦卡锡？
But as far as Jon Smith personally goes, he buried the lead on this call. Hassan checks his email while we're on the phone.
但就乔恩·史密斯个人而言，他在这次通话中埋下了伏笔。当我们还在通话时，哈桑查了他的邮件。
"Jon Smith's resignation"? Jon Smith.
“乔恩·史密斯辞职”？乔恩·史密斯。
As district chair?
作为区主席？
Jon? What are you thinking, man?
乔恩？你在想什么，伙计？
I'm trying to understand why you decided to resign.
我正在试图理解你为什么要决定辞职。
I can't-- I can't afford to play the game anymore.
我不能——我负担不起再玩这个游戏了。
What are you going to--
你要去做什么——
It's an expensive hobby.
这是一种昂贵的爱好。
What are you going to do for work?
你要去做什么工作？
Construction work.
建筑工作。
I'm hiring.
我在招聘。
So I quit, because I can't afford to play, man. It's expensive, going across the district, you know? And it's just, uh-- it's hard on the bank, man. To be honest with you, I wake up to politics 24/7. So I mean, I need to get off the mindset and get into work.
所以我辞职了，因为我玩不起，伙计。这很贵，穿过选区，你知道吗？这只是，呃——这对银行来说很难，伙计。说实话，我24/7都被政治唤醒。所以我的意思是，我需要摆脱这种心态，投入工作。
I mean, I'm right there with you, man. It's--
我的意思是，我同意你的看法，伙计。它——
I drive a 2000 Saturn with one fender, guys.
我开着一辆带有挡泥板的2000年土星车，伙计们。
Hey. I mean, I put 90,000 miles on my truck, and I was forced to buy my lease because of this, and spent a lot of-- I promise you, I'm in the same boat, and it's-- ugh. But I'm just hoping we-- you know, it works.
嘿。我的意思是，我的卡车跑了9万英里，因为这个我被迫买下我的租赁车，花了很多——我向你保证，我在同一条船上，而且它——呃。但我只是希望我们——你知道，它能行。
It doesn't-- it doesn't-- it's not working out. [CHUCKLES]
它没有——它没有——它行不通。[轻笑]
That is an interesting question to me. These leadership roles are volunteer, not paid. Like, did the party only work before because there were rich people who could afford to do them?
这对我有意思。这些领导角色是志愿的，不是付费的。就像，这个党以前能运作只是因为有富人能负担得起做这些事吗？
How long can the not-rich people afford to be in political leadership here? Of all the people to leave now, I'm surprised it's Jon. You know, he was one of the first people in Michigan to make a show of pushing out the establishment-- part of this wave of new leaders who ousted their county chairs to create this grassroots state party, run by the newbies, disconnected from the old guard. He walked so Kristina could run.
非富人能负担得起在这里担任政治领导多久？在所有现在要离开的人中，我很惊讶是乔恩。你知道，他是密歇根州第一批高调推翻建制派的人之一——这些新领袖浪潮的一部分，他们罢免了他们的县主席，创建了这个草根州党，由新手经营，与旧势力断开了联系。他走了，所以克里斯蒂娜可以跑。
As for Hassan and Ali, they hadn't found the party an especially welcoming place, either before or after Kristina's takeover. But they're going to keep trying. Seeing how hard they're having to fight to be included, it makes me think about how relatively unimportant winning seems to be in post-January 6 purity politics.
至于哈桑和阿里，他们在克里斯蒂娜接管前后都没有发现党内是一个特别受欢迎的地方。但他们会继续努力。看到他们为被包括在内而奋斗得如此艰难，这让我想到了在1月6日后的纯度政治中，获胜似乎相对不重要。
Like, if the party wanted to win, you could imagine a world where they'd be reaching out to guys like this instead of sidelining them. But instead, it seems that this new version of the party is winnowing it down to a relatively small, untainted-by-compromise group of principled people. Not a winning strategy for a political party-- in Michigan in particular.
就像，如果该党想赢，你可以想象一个世界，他们会联系像这些人一样的人，而不是把他们边缘化。但相反，这个新版本的党似乎正在把它缩小到一个相对较小、没有妥协、有原则的群体。这不是一个政治党的制胜策略——特别是在密歇根州。
Zoe Chace. Coming up, how to topple a Republican leader? Well, like somebody said a half-century ago, follow the money. It's about to get real. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·查斯。接下来，如何推翻共和党领导人？好吧，就像半个世纪前某人说的，跟随金钱。它要变得真实了。那是芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后的内容，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. As this year ends, noticing the kind of fights happening among Republicans in the US House of Representatives and around the country, we have this political story that we thought captures something about the state of Republican politics this year from Michigan. We're calling the episode, "It Wouldn't Be Make Believe if You'd Believe in Me." Zoe Chace picks up where she left off.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。随着今年结束，注意到美国众议院和全国各地共和党人之间发生的各种争斗，我们有这个政治故事，我们认为它捕捉到了今年密歇根州共和党政治的状态。我们把这一集称为，“如果你相信我，这就不可能是假装的。”佐伊·查斯接着她留下的地方继续。
The last week of September, the plot to oust Kristina heated up, when someone in the Michigan GOP sent out a barrage of screenshots to a few reporters. They were of bank statements of the Michigan GOP. It was a little confusing, this collection of random screenshots, but it did seem like the party was almost completely out of money.
9月的最后一周，罢免克里斯蒂娜的阴谋升温了，当时密歇根共和党内有人向几位记者发送了一连串的截图。那是密歇根共和党的银行对账单。这有点令人困惑，这堆随机的截图，但看起来党确实几乎完全没钱了。
Jon Smith got the texts. He didn't see any evidence of this thing Kristina's people had said at Mackinac about the money they'd raised. He was depressed.
乔恩·史密斯收到了短信。他没有看到克里斯蒂娜的人在麦基诺说的关于他们筹集的钱的任何证据。他很沮丧。
And they just told us we raised $600,000, which is a lie. They're lying, Zoe. They're lying. They're lying to everyone.
他们刚才告诉我们筹集了60万美元，那是谎言。他们在撒谎，佐伊。他们在撒谎。他们对每个人都在撒谎。
I guess, do you think they're lying because they're, like, corrupt? Or do you think they're lying because they're scared?
我猜，你认为他们在撒谎是因为他们腐败？还是你认为他们在撒谎是因为他们害怕？
I think they're scared. That's what I'm saying. We would be OK with it if they would just open the books. We would help them. If we need to raise $150,000 this weekend, we would all go out as a united front across the state of Michigan and make it happen. They're choosing to be deceptive.
我认为他们害怕。这就是我所说的。如果他们愿意公开账目，我们会没事的。我们会帮助他们。如果我们需要在这个周末筹集15万美元，我们会作为密歇根州的统一战线走出去，让它实现。他们选择了欺骗。
Like, you think that if from the very beginning they had said, hey, we're not going to any of the old donors, we're doing a whole new thing, so we need you guys to fundraise, like, all the time, people would have gone with that?
就像，你认为如果从一开始他们就说，嘿，我们不去找任何旧捐赠者，我们在做一件全新的事，所以我们需要你们筹款，就像，一直这样，人们会接受吗？
I don't know. But they could have just been honest right from the get-go.
我不知道。但他们本可以从一开始就诚实的。
You don't feel bad leaving people kind of in the middle of this mess?
你不觉得让人们在这种混乱中感觉不好吗？
No, I can't, Zoe. I got to go to work.
不，我不能，佐伊。我得去工作。
People were getting scared that the party was in no way going to be able to run next year's elections. There would be no fundraising, no Get Out the Vote, no coordination of strategy. They were going to lose control of 2024. And that brings us to Act 3, "The Insurrectionists Insurrect Again."
人们开始害怕该党明年无论如何都无法进行选举。将没有筹款，没有选民动员，没有战略协调。他们将失去对2024年的控制。这把我们带到了第三幕，“叛乱分子再次叛乱”。
The guy who leaked the bank account screenshots-- Warren Carpenter-- was a major Kristina supporter at first. Warren helped get Kristina elected. He raised money for her secretary-of-state campaign. He whipped votes for her chair race.
泄露银行账户截图的家伙——沃伦·卡彭特——起初是克里斯蒂娜的坚定支持者。沃伦帮助克里斯蒂娜当选。他为她的州务卿竞选筹集资金。他为她的主席竞选争取选票。
I went to talk to him. He runs a landscaping business in the suburbs of Detroit. He walked me to the back of his office.
我去找他谈话。他在底特律郊区经营一家景观美化公司。他带我走到他的办公室后面。
This is uncomfortable.
这不舒服。
Is it?
是吗？
Yeah. I don't like it.
是的。我不喜欢它。
You'll get used to it.
你会习惯的。
Ah, I don't like it. I don't want to do that. You want to record me?
啊，我不喜欢。我不想那样做。你想录音我吗？
Well, it's radio. That's why.
好吧，这是广播。这就是为什么。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Warren comes off antagonistic right from the beginning, and a little manic. What he's just done-- leaking documents to the press about Kristina-- it's a big deal, though.
沃伦从一开始就表现出对抗性，还有点躁狂。他刚才所做的——向媒体泄露关于克里斯蒂娜的文件——这是一件大事。
How are you? You got a lot going on?
你好吗？你有很多事情在忙吗？
Well-- [LAUGHS] It's like you didn't read the news or something.
嗯——[笑声] 就像你没看新闻或者什么的一样。
"It's like you didn't read the news or something," he says. That morning, the morning we spoke, September 29, Detroit News reporter Craig Mauger, an eminently fair and lightning-fast journalist, published a write-up of all the documents Warren had sent him.
“就像你没看新闻或者什么的一样，”他说。那天早上，我们交谈的那天早上，9月29日，底特律新闻报记者克雷格·莫格，一位极其公正且速度极快的记者，发表了一份沃伦发给他的所有文件的摘要。
The article begins, "The Michigan Republican Party had about $35,000 in its bank account in August, according to internal records that flashed new warning signs about the dire state of the GOP's finances." This is followed shortly by a quote from a former state GOP official-- "These numbers demonstrate that the party isn't just broke, but broken."
文章开头写道，“根据内部记录，密歇根共和党在8月份的银行账户中大约只有3.5万美元，这些记录为该党惨淡的财务状况亮起了新的警示信号。”紧随其后的是前州共和党官员的一段话——“这些数字表明，该党不仅没钱，而且已经破产了。”
Warren is also extensively quoted in the article, which is a big betrayal of Kristina, talking to a journalist who, in her view, is just in league with the establishment trying to take her out. Warren says he dabbled in Republican politics before this movement took off, worked on a statewide campaign over 10 years ago, but not much since then, until Trump.
沃伦也在文章中被广泛引用，这对克里斯蒂娜来说是一个巨大的背叛，他向一位在他看来只是与试图搞垮她的建制派串通一气的记者谈话。沃伦说他在这个运动起飞前涉足过共和党政治，十多年前在全州范围的竞选中工作过，但之后就没怎么做过，直到特朗普出现。
He loves Trump, calls him Big Daddy, and had that school board come-to-Jesus so many Republicans did around the COVID protocols-- masking in schools kind of thing. He went to January 6 after he thought he saw the election get stolen. Says he didn't go inside the Capitol, but he had such an intense experience there, that not long after, he had a mental breakdown, as he puts it.
他热爱特朗普，称他为“大爹地”，并且有了许多共和党人在新冠协议周围所经历的那种校董会觉悟——学校戴口罩之类的事情。他在认为看到选举被窃取后去了1月6日。他说他没有进入国会大厦，但他在那里有如此强烈的体验，以至于没过多久，正如他所说，他精神崩溃了。
That's when he got involved in his local party. He's one of the newbies who got elected to district chair, part of the wave that took over the party this year. He'd been part of Kristina's inner circle, but now, he'd resigned from his position as district chair and was talking smack in the press. So what happened?
就在那时，他参与了当地政党。他是当选为区主席的新人之一，今年接管该党浪潮的一部分。他一直是克里斯蒂娜核心圈子的一员，但现在，他辞去了区主席的职务，并在媒体上谈论她的坏话。那么发生了什么？
Well, a few weeks before the Mackinac conference, Warren got on the phone with Kristina's chief of staff, Joel Studebaker, and the rest of her team. And they were telling him they needed help to pull off the conference. So he looked at their financial situation, and he responded with what I now understand to be his typical intensity.
嗯，在麦基诺会议前几周，沃伦与克里斯蒂娜的办公厅主任乔尔·斯图德贝克和她的团队通了电话。他们告诉他，他们需要帮助来完成会议。所以他看了看他们的财务状况，并以我现在理解为他典型的强度做出了回应。
How much money do you have? How much money do we need? How much money are we owed? Who's been paid? Right?
你有多少钱？我们需要多少钱？我们被欠了多少钱？谁被支付了？对吧？
What's the problem? What do you need? Why am I on the fucking call with you? But like, Joel Studebaker didn't know what the numbers were.
问题是什么？你需要什么？为什么我在该死的电话里和你在一起？但乔尔·斯图德贝克不知道数字是什么。
Like, they didn't know any of the numbers for anything. They were literally flying by the fucking seat of their pants, shooting from the hip. It was-- I mean, it was the most ludicrous thing I've ever heard of in my entire life.
就像，他们根本不知道任何事情的数字。他们字面意思是在凭着该死的裤子飞行，凭直觉行事。它是——我的意思是，这是我一生中听过的最荒谬的事情。
Like, there was no budgetary schematic they could share with me. And during that initial Friday call, the only thing they had to share was like, they almost had the program ready to go to the printer.
就像，没有预算示意图可以与我分享。在那次初步的周五电话会议期间，他们唯一能分享的是，他们几乎准备好程序去打印。
A program with speakers on it they didn't have the cash to pay for, it seemed. Warren called campaign finance experts, who looked at what he had and told him to get as far away as possible from this organization.
一个演讲者名单上的程序，他们似乎没有现金支付。沃伦致电竞选财务专家，他们看了他拥有的东西，并告诉他尽可能远离这个组织。
I've looked at Warren's documents, and what I saw looked like a broke party, spending money way faster than it was taking anything in. I also went over the party's FEC filings, though they haven't filed since July. In all that I looked at, I did see some very unusual accounting, but nothing illegal, like Warren alleges.
我看了沃伦的文件，我看到的是一个破产的政党，花钱的速度远远超过它拿进来的速度。我还查阅了该党的FEC文件，尽管他们自7月以来就没有提交过。在我看的所有东西中，我确实看到了一些非常不寻常的会计，但没有什么非法的，像沃伦指控的那样。
So there's only two ways that this could-- there's only two things that this could possibly be, in my mind, all right? It is either gross negligence, incompetence, right? I would ascribe intent and say that it's malicious. And therefore, if it's malicious, then you have to go to the next conclusion, which is, then it's destruction of the party. Now, can you ascribe intent for destruction of the party?
所以只有两种方法可能——只有两件事可能是，在我看来，好吧？要么是重大疏忽，无能，对吧？我会归因于意图并说这是恶意的。因此，如果它是恶意的，那么你必须得出下一个结论，即，它是对党的破坏。现在，你能把对党的破坏归因于意图吗？
Warren goes on to float his own version of the sabotage theory I heard from other people, that Kristina herself is controlled by some kind of national operation, launched at the Michigan Republican Party in order to destroy it.
沃伦继续提出他自己版本的我从其他人那里听到的破坏理论，即克里斯蒂娜本人受到某种全国行动的控制，旨在摧毁它。
Either an operative or it's a fed. But it's either from the Democratic side or it's from an agency.
要么是特工，要么是联邦调查局。但它要么来自民主党方面，要么来自某个机构。
He's pretty sure it's an op and that it's not just in Michigan. That would explain why GOPs in Georgia, Arizona, and Idaho are struggling. Someone's sabotaging them. But even if it's not an op, as someone who helped put Kristina in office in the first place, Warren now feels responsible for where she's brought the party.
他非常确定这是一个行动，而且不仅仅在密歇根州。这将解释为什么乔治亚州、亚利桑那州和爱达荷州的共和党都在挣扎。有人在破坏他们。但即使这不是一个行动，作为一个起初帮助克里斯蒂娜上任的人，沃伦现在觉得对她把党带到的地方负责。
And Warren's a doer. He's also make-amends-er. I find that out myself when he calls me and apologizes for yelling at me at one point. Maybe that comes from his years in AA.
沃伦是个实干家。他也是个弥补者。我自己发现了这一点，当他打电话给我并为在某一点上对我大喊大叫道歉时。也许这来自于他在匿名戒酒会（AA）工作的岁月。
So Warren has a plan to make things right. Oust Kristina Karamo. He has a whole 18-point plan to do it. That Detroit News article was a first step. Now he's whipping votes against her, just like he whipped votes for her at the beginning of the year, trying to make sure he has the numbers.
所以沃伦有一个纠正事情的计划。罢免克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫。他有一个完整的18点计划来做到这一点。底特律新闻报的文章是第一步。现在他正在为反对她争取选票，就像他在年初为她争取选票一样，试图确保他有足够的人数。
You file for the meeting. When we get the signatures, we're going to have all the signatures needed to overthrow. So then it just shows them, it's over. I want psychologically for them to be beat before they even go into this. And it's over.
你申请会议。当我们获得签名时，我们将拥有罢免所需的所有签名。所以它只是向他们展示，结束了。在他们进入这个会议之前，我想在心理上让他们被打败。结束了。
Uh, OK, everybody, I just want to get started real quick about why everyone's on the phone call.
呃，好吧，大家，我只是想快速开始为什么每个人都在电话会议上。
The next time I hear Warren's voice, it's from a Zoom meeting someone sent me of state committee members from around Michigan. Warren called the meeting. He has a spreadsheet of the 100-or-so people in the state committee color-coded-- who's with him, who's against him. He's literally counting votes, trying to get to that majority to oust Kristina.
我下次听到沃伦的声音，是从某人发给我的密歇根州委员会成员的Zoom会议。沃伦召开了会议。他有一个关于州委员会中大约100人左右的电子表格，按颜色编码——谁站在他这边，谁反对他。他字面意思是在点票，试图达到罢免克里斯蒂娜的多数票。
OK, so let's go through this real quick. Everybody in red is in red until they're probably confirmed otherwise. So I need some people to speak up as we go through some of these. I mean, Andy, is there anybody in your district that's not on board with this? Andy? You muted? All right.
好吧，让我们快速浏览一下。红色中的每个人都在红色中，直到他们可能被另行确认。所以当我浏览其中一些时，我需要一些人发言。我的意思是，安迪，你所在选区有没有人不支持这个？安迪？你静音了吗？好吧。
No, they're all-- all those people are for this.
不，他们都是——所有人都是支持这个的。
That's not Andy. That's Jon Smith. Despite having quit as district chair, he can't stay away. Warren and Jon go back and forth on whether or not they have a 2/3 majority. Or do they only need 50%?
那不是安迪。那是乔恩·史密斯。尽管辞去了区主席职务，但他无法远离。沃伦和乔恩来回讨论他们是否拥有2/3的多数。还是他们只需要50%？
Listen, if we don't have enough, if we don't have 2/3, we don't call the fucking meeting. Right? Nancy Pelosi doesn't bring anything to the floor if it doesn't have all the fucking votes. Neither do I.
听着，如果我们没有足够的人，如果我们没有2/3，我们就不能召开那个该死的会议。对吧？南希·佩洛西如果没有任何该死的选票，就不会把任何东西带到现场。我也不。
So I mean, that's it right there. You got the 2/3 to call the meeting. It's over. I'm telling you. So let me just-- just trust me on this, please, guys. I know I'm forceful, and I'm sorry.
所以我的意思是，那就是它了。你获得了召开会议的2/3。结束了。我告诉你。所以让我只是——只是相信我，求你了，伙计们。我知道我很强硬，我很抱歉。
I'm a boss, and nobody ever tells me no, and that's why I'm not good at this job. That's why I'm not a good district chair, and I'm not good at collaboration stuff. And please don't take my forcefulness for trying to beat up on anybody. It's not what I'm trying to do. I'm trying to convince you that this is a--
我是个老板，没人敢拒绝我，这就是为什么我不擅长这份工作。这就是为什么我不是一个好的区主席，我不擅长协作之类的东西。请不要把我的强硬误解为试图殴打任何人。这不是我试图做的。我试图说服你们这是一个——
Well, we're at the threshold of 50%. That's what I'm telling people when I'm talking to people is like, do we not move forward, or where do we get to the point where we have to start having this discussion? So I think we're at that point with 54 people. I mean, that's a significant number.
好吧，我们处于50%的门槛。这就是我告诉人们的话，当我与人们交谈时就像，我们不向前推进，或者我们到了什么程度必须开始进行这种讨论？所以我认为我们在54人这个点上。我的意思是，这是一个重要的数字。
That's more than 50%. We are the majority on state committee at this point without whipping a single fucking person.
这超过了50%。我们现在是州委员会的多数，没有鞭策任何该死的人。
Then who shows up in the Zoom? The guy Warren lined up to replace Karamo. And guess who it is? Scott Greenlee. Yes, Scott Greenlee, the guy who ran for chair from the beginning of the story, who wasn't America-first enough to get elected in the first place. Remember?
那么谁出现在了Zoom里？沃伦安排替换卡拉莫的家伙。猜猜是谁？斯科特·格林利。是的，斯科特·格林利，那个从故事开始就竞选主席的家伙，他不够美国优先以至于最初没有当选。记得吗？
I'm called establishment. I get called a RINO. That's even worse.
我被称为建制派。我被称为“共和党内建制派”（RINO）。那更糟。
Now, he makes his pitch to this renegade faction that he should be the choice of the renegade faction. And he cuts quickly to the chase.
现在，他向这个反叛派别推销自己，他应该是反叛派别的选择。他很快进入了正题。
I think I could probably raise $1/2 million in the first week, a couple million by the end of the year, 5 by March, and salvage the cycle with about $10 million in total fundraising. And certainly, we have the challenge that some people wouldn't like, necessarily, everyone who is donating to the party. But I would welcome any and all dollars, within reason.
我想我可能在第一周筹集到50万美元，到年底几百万，到三月500万，并以总共约1000万美元的筹款来挽救这个周期。当然，我们面临着一些人可能不一定喜欢向该党捐款的每一个人的挑战。但我会欢迎任何和所有的美元，在合理范围内。
I mean, certainly, if Hillary Clinton moved to Michigan and said she wanted to help, I'd be a little suspicious. But short of that, if people want to help this party rebuild, they're going to get an open door not a closed door.
我的意思是，当然，如果希拉里·克林顿搬到密歇根州说她想帮忙，我会有点怀疑。但除此之外，如果人们想帮助这个政党重建，他们将得到一扇敞开的门，而不是一扇关闭的门。
Some donors won't come back, Greenlee says. It's going to be a hard sales job to go to people who've been demonized. Of course, I'll include grassroots, but we all got to play nice together. Warren interrupts him.
一些捐赠者不会回来，格林利说。去那些被妖魔化的人那里做销售工作将是一项艰巨的任务。当然，我会包括草根，但我们都必须很好地相处。沃伦打断了他。
Hey, Scott. I had a question sent to me. How can you assure us that John Yob will not be running the party?
嘿，斯科特。我收到一个问题。你如何保证约翰·尤布不会经营这个党？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
John Yob is a powerful political consultant in Michigan. He's been around, a political director for the John McCain campaign, symbol of the hated establishment.
约翰·尤布是密歇根州一位强大的政治顾问。他在那里呆过，约翰·麦凯恩竞选活动的政治主管，受人憎恨的建制派的象征。
Uh, because I'll be the chairman. I mean--
呃，因为我会是主席。我的意思是——
Real questions, man. This is--
真正的问题，伙计。这是——
Hey-- hey, Scott? Hey, Scott? This is Jon. That would be a real question. You know, you just said you have a hard time identifying what is grassroots and stuff like that. But that is a legit question.
嘿——嘿，斯科特？嘿，斯科特？我是乔恩。那将是一个真正的问题。你知道，你刚才说你很难识别什么是草根之类的东西。但那是一个合法的问题。
Sure. So John and I have worked together. John and I have worked against each other. But you know, unless you guys are liking John Yob as chair, he's not running the party. I guarantee that. I'll take his input when it makes sense. That's for sure.
当然。所以约翰和我一起工作过。约翰和我一起反对过对方。但你知道，除非你们喜欢约翰·尤布作为主席，否则他不经营这个党。我保证这一点。当有意义时，我会接受他的意见。那是肯定的。
I don't want to close anybody out. I don't want to manage by exclusion. I think we need everybody pushing in the same direction. But I will make the decisions the chairman needs to make. And you elect me, and I'll be running the party.
我不想排除任何人。我不想通过排斥来管理。我认为我们需要每个人都朝着同一个方向努力。但我会做出主席需要做出的决定。你们选我，我就会经营这个党。
Greenlee-- from another era, it sounds like-- talking to consultants, raising money, being inclusive, bringing people in, instead of cutting people out. The call ends shortly after that. They don't quite have the numbers to oust Kristina. I can't tell how Greenlee went over. Jon's not sure either. He and Warren chat afterwards.
格林利——来自另一个时代，听起来——与顾问交谈，筹集资金，具有包容性，把人们带进来，而不是把人们切出去。通话在此后不久结束。他们没有足够的人数罢免克里斯蒂娜。我看不出格林利是怎么过去的。乔恩也不确定。他和沃伦之后聊天。
Hey, Warren.
嘿，沃伦。
What up, Jonny?
怎么了，强尼？
I put Tom in the waiting room. What are you--
我把汤姆放在候诊室了。你——
What'd you think?
你怎么想？
Yeah, that's what I was going to ask you.
是的，那是我要问你的。
Uh, like, here's the thing.
呃，就像这里的事情。
Warren's moving a million miles an hour. He's like, Scott or not, I know I'm going to get the votes to remove her. Jon's still stuck on whether the grassroots will stomach him.
沃伦以每小时一百万英里的速度移动。他就像，斯科特也好，别的也好，我知道我会获得罢免她的选票。乔恩仍然纠结于草根是否能容忍他。
I think he's an honest guy.
我认为他是一个诚实的人。
Yeah, he's super honest, dude.
是的，他超级诚实，伙计。
You know what I mean? Like, if he says he's going to do it, I think he will do that.
你知道我的意思吗？就像，如果他说他会做，我想他会做。
Yeah. Because there's a reason he's the only guy that's still allowed in all the rooms, dude. All the rest of these consultants are like ghosts. They're like vapors.
是的。因为有一个原因他是唯一仍然被允许进入所有房间的家伙，伙计。所有这些顾问剩下的就像鬼魂。他们就像蒸汽。
You don't ever see 'em anywhere. They're always lurking. Like, he's out in the open every single day, like, posting on Facebook about how to be a good leader, dude. You know what I mean?
你永远看不到他们去任何地方。他们总是潜伏着。就像，他每天都在外面，就像，在Facebook上发帖关于如何做一个好领袖，伙计。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. I'm wondering if Scott Greenlee is salvageable to the delegates. And I think he very well could be. It's not like we got that many options, though. [CHUCKLES]
是的。我想知道斯科特·格林利是否对代表们有挽救价值。我认为他很可能。不过，不是我们有很多选择。[轻笑]
Hey, listen, my wife--
嘿，听着，我的妻子——
Do your thing.
做你的事。
Night, brother.
晚安，兄弟。
Good night.
晚安。
Act Four, Karamo Fights Back.
第四幕，卡拉莫反击。
There's been a coup attempt to overthrow Kristina, and they've got a bunch of people that were lying. OK? You want to know some of the lies that were out there?
有一场推翻克里斯蒂娜的政变，他们有一群人撒谎了。好吧？你想知道外面的一些谎言吗？
Sure.
当然。
Oh, Kristina went to meet Donald Trump for dinner, and she came in a swimsuit and a cover-up.
哦，克里斯蒂娜去和唐纳德·特朗普吃晚餐，她穿着泳衣和罩衫。
This is Darlene, Kristina supporter. I'm at a pasta dinner, called by Kristina's chief of staff, in a swanky ballroom in the suburbs of Detroit. The invitation read, "Join MIGOP Chief of Staff Joel Studebaker as he offers a rebuttal to claims of impropriety." In other words, spaghetti, meatballs, a PowerPoint for dessert. Darlene's here for it.
这是达琳，克里斯蒂娜的支持者。我在一个意大利面晚宴上，由克里斯蒂娜的办公厅主任召集，在底特律郊区一个豪华宴会厅里。邀请函上写着，“加入密歇根共和党办公厅主任乔尔·斯图德贝克，因为他为不当行为的说法提供了反驳。”换句话说，意大利面，肉丸，甜点的PPT。达琳就在这里。
All right? They're kind of manipulating things to where it looks one way. Kristina has not drawn a paycheck since July. All right?
好吧？他们以一种看起来像那样的方式操纵事情。克里斯蒂娜自七月以来没有领过薪水。好吧？
You can see that in some of the filings.
你可以在一些文件中看到这一点。
First of all, they said, oh, Mackinac is not going to happen. She's skimming the money. The speakers aren't getting paid. It's going to end up in the parking lot. Don't go. Refund your ticket. Mackinac was a huge success.
首先，他们说，哦，麦基诺不会发生。她在撇开钱。演讲者没有得到报酬。它最终会停在停车场。别去。退你的票。麦基诺是一个巨大的成功。
Kristina went back to what a conference should be-- God, country, and party, and family. She went there. She didn't go with all the dinner parties, all the different drinking parties.
克里斯蒂娜回到了会议应该有的样子——上帝，国家，党，和家庭。她去了那里。她没有带着所有的晚宴，所有的不同的饮酒派对。
She went to bring us all back to our roots. She is grassroots, and she's grassroots all the way. She is not selling out. She never has, and she never will.
她是为了带我们所有人回到我们的根源。她是草根，她是草根到底。她没有出卖。她从来没有，也永远不会。
Downstairs, in the room literally just below this one, in another giant ballroom, is Warren, sitting alone with his laptop, a projector behind him. He booked the room at 3:00 PM today, after he heard he was going to be barred from attending Kristina's rebuttal event. He's wearing a red baseball cap that says "Trump was right," and he's totally by himself.
楼下，在字面意义上就在这个房间下面的房间，在另一个巨大的宴会厅里，是沃伦，一个人坐在他的笔记本电脑旁，身后有一个投影仪。他在今天下午3点预订了这个房间，在他听说他将被禁止参加克里斯蒂娜的反驳活动后。他戴着一顶写着“特朗普是对的”的红色棒球帽，而且他完全是一个人。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I was like, is it him? How are you doing, man?
我就像，是他吗？你好吗，伙计？
Come on in.
进来吧。
Hi. So?
嗨。所以？
What's up?
怎么了？
I don't know. Does it feel weird, everybody upstairs and you down here?
我不知道。每个人都在楼上，你在这里，这感觉很奇怪吗？
No.
不。
Really?
真的吗？
Swear to God, dude.
向神发誓，伙计。
OK.
好吧。
Yeah.
是的。
Because I know, like, you lost all your friends, and that must feel hard.
因为我知道，就像，你失去了所有的朋友，那一定感觉很艰难。
Oh, are we doing the thing right now?
哦，我们现在在做那件事吗？
I'm always recording.
我一直在录音。
OK, well, I don't know, man. You come over with the microphone, I'm not sure.
好的，好吧，我不知道，伙计。你拿着麦克风过来，我不确定。
Sorry.
抱歉。
OK.
好吧。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
It's taking Warren longer than he expected to execute his 18-point plan. Because, as he says, he's a vote counter, and he hasn't been getting enough people on the board. And last week, he got invited to a meeting of the Macomb County GOP to present his documents and make his case.
沃伦执行他的18点计划比他预期的要长。因为，正如他所说，他是一个投票计数器，而且他在委员会里没有获得足够多的人。上周，他被邀请参加密歇根共和党马科姆县会议，以提交他的文件并陈述他的情况。
He put up a rapidfire slideshow for the delegates to convince them that Kristina was a fraud. And honestly, he sounded slightly unhinged. Here's some Facebook video of that event.
他为代表们放映了一个快速幻灯片，以说服他们克里斯蒂娜是个骗子。说实话，他听起来有点精神失常。这是一些关于那个活动的Facebook视频。
Guess what? There's more! There's another one! Wait! There's four more! Over $100,000 that can't be accounted for in deposits! (YELLING) This is your party!
你猜怎么着？还有更多！还有另一个！等等！还有四个！超过10万美元在存款中无法解释！（大喊）这是你的党！
But he's raised enough heat that Karamo's people decided they want to respond publicly to his claims. Hence the pasta dinner and counterpresentation. For Warren's part, he's here to respond to the response to his claims and try to keep his cool.
但他引起了足够的热度，卡拉莫的人决定他们想公开回应他的说法。因此，意大利面晚宴和反演示。就沃伦而言，他在这里是对回应他的说法做出回应，并试图保持冷静。
My whole motive of coming tonight was I'm just going to be calm.
我今晚来的全部动机是我只是要冷静。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
Right? And I was going to answer people's questions if they had concerns. And--
对吧？如果人们有顾虑，我会回答他们的问题。而且——
Are you in the middle of an interview?
你正在采访中吗？
Someone comes in and asks, are you in the middle of an interview?
有人进来问，你正在采访中吗？
Yeah, she's talking to me just real quick. But do you want to talk?
是的，她刚才确实和我谈话。但你想谈谈吗？
I just wanted to bring her up to speed on what's going on down here. Can you give her a kind of an overview?
我只是想让她了解这里发生了什么。你能给她一个概述吗？
Yeah. So anybody that wants to ask anything after all this is done, they come down here, and I'll open up documents, show them whatever they want to see.
是的。所以任何人在这一切完成后想问任何事情，他们就到这里来，我会打开文件，向他们展示他们想看到的任何东西。
Are they the same documents you put up?
它们是你放上去的那些文件吗？
I got everything-- I got everything that I got.
我拥有所有东西——我拥有我得到的每一件事。
If you had pasta, I'd stay.
如果你有意大利面，我会留下。
Then it would-- I get it, I get it.
那它会——我懂了，我懂了。
You gotta spend the money.
你得花钱。
You got some curious customers.
你有一些好奇的顾客。
In the ballroom upstairs, it's maybe 75 people. Kristina's chief of staff, Joel Studebaker, is presenting a rebuttal to Warren's crazed Facebook video. He opens with a Bible verse, but then gets surprisingly detailed, shows snapshots of bank statements. After complaining that the previous administration left them with little money and some debt, which is true, there's this admission.
在楼上的宴会厅里，大约有75人。克里斯蒂娜的办公厅主任乔尔·斯图德贝克正在对沃伦疯狂的Facebook视频做出反驳。他以一段圣经经文开头，但随后变得令人惊讶地详细，展示了银行对账单的快照。在抱怨前任政府给他们留下的钱很少和一些债务（这是真的）之后，有了这个承认。
Here's the reality. Fundraising has been a challenge. It's been very difficult. A lot of these things, you know, they're just realities. And we need help. We do need help.
这是现实。筹款一直是一个挑战。一直非常困难。许多这些事情，你知道，它们只是现实。我们需要帮助。我们确实需要帮助。
But you got to be able to work together. And there's no way we're going to do that if we keep giving liberal media interviews and if we keep walking through demonization schemes. It's just not going to happen. So we need help, and we need to do it the right way. We need to collaborate.
但你必须能够一起工作。如果我们继续接受自由派媒体采访，如果我们继续走过妖魔化计划，我们是不可能做到这一点的。这只是不会发生。所以我们需要帮助，我们需要以正确的方式做到这一点。我们需要协作。
Yes, we do. Yes!
是的，我们需要。是的！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
When Kristina finally speaks, she talks about finances, about Mackinac, and she's frank. She admits they would have liked to make a lot more money off the conference. They're still in debt for $110,000 speaker's fee-- for Jim Caviezel, for example.
当克里斯蒂娜最终发言时，她谈到了财政，谈到了麦基诺，而且她很坦率。她承认他们本来希望从会议中赚到更多的钱。他们仍然欠着11万美元的演讲费——例如，给吉姆·卡维泽的。
She reminds everyone that the reason they elected her is they wanted to run the party differently, not raise $20 million and run right through it like previous chairs.
她提醒每个人，他们选她的原因是他们想以不同的方式经营政党，而不是筹集2000万美元并像以前的主席那样花掉它。
So where did all this $20 million go? What was it spent on? Oh, I know, a bunch of consultants who did nothing. So that's what it was spent on.
那么所有这2000万美元去哪了？它花在什么上了？哦，我知道，一群什么都没做的顾问。所以这就是它花在什么上了。
I mean, where did all the money get-- people brag about how much money they raised, and then go pay off their friends. So that what's been going on for decades. So yes, we disrupted that system. So you know--
我的意思是，所有的钱都去哪了——人们吹嘘他们筹集了多少钱，然后去支付他们的朋友。所以那就是几十年来一直在发生的事情。所以是的，我们扰乱了那个系统。所以你知道——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
She spoke for 20 minutes, no pauses or hesitations, mostly informing the crowd of mostly supporters that she was the victim of a deep-state conspiracy to take her out.
她讲了20分钟，没有停顿或犹豫，主要是通知大多数支持者群体，她是深层政府阴谋搞垮她的受害者。
Again, this whole deep-state thing is very real. It is very real. Because their goal is that if these people don't succeed, not just here, but also places like Colorado, Kansas, Georgia, where you have a bunch of America-first chairs, the goal for these people is, if these people fail, then a grassroots person won't dare run for chair.
再次，这个深层政府的东西是非常真实的。它是非常真实的。因为他们的目标是，如果这些人不成功，不仅在这里，而且在像科罗拉多、堪萨斯、乔治亚这样的地方，你有许多美国优先的主席，这些人的目标是，如果这些人失败了，那么一个草根的人就不会敢于竞选主席。
And a lot of the people who may or may not want to support a grassroots person for chair wouldn't do it because it's like, well, last time, it was so horrible. We can never do it again.
而且许多可能或可能不想支持草根主席的人不会这样做，因为就像，嗯，上次，那太可怕了。我们永远不能再做一次。
She called out the people she sees as covert deep-state operatives within the current party. When she describes them, they sound a lot like Warren.
她呼吁那些她在当前党内视为秘密深层政府特工的人。当她描述他们时，他们听起来很像沃伦。
And the thing about it is, these people-- they pretend to be patriots like us so they can get close to us. They pretend to be one of us so we will trust them.
关于它的一点是，这些人——他们假装像我们一样是爱国者，这样他们就可以接近我们。他们假装是我们需要的一员，这样我们就会信任他们。
Moving on next to Ali and Hassan, not by name.
接下来移动到阿里和哈桑，没有点名。
I mean, I had two vice chairs falsely accuse me of being a bigot against Muslims.
我的意思是，我有两位副主席错误地指控我是一个对穆斯林有偏见的人。
But she insists, her administration hasn't ever lied or committed any crimes. The fighting itself, she says, is a tactic to keep her from succeeding. The fighting, however, immediately continues.
但她坚持认为，她的行政部门从未撒谎或犯下任何罪行。她说，战斗本身是一种战术，旨在阻止她成功。然而，战斗立即继续。
Back downstairs in Warren's room, a guy from Kristina's team swaggers in to confront Warren. His name's Ken Beyer. He said he'd received a text from Warren saying, I'm coming after you. Warren says, it just said, I'm coming. And there's this big Wild-West-y faceoff between them.
回到楼下沃伦的房间，克里斯蒂娜团队的一个家伙大摇大摆地进来与沃伦对质。他的名字叫肯·拜尔。他说他收到沃伦的一条短信，说，我来找你了。沃伦说，它只是说，我来了。他们之间有这一场大型西部风格的对峙。
Hey, Ken! You going to ask some questions?
嘿，肯！你要问一些问题吗？
Oh, I just [INAUDIBLE]. If you're going to threaten me, do it to my face.
哦，我只是[听不清]。如果你要威胁我，当面做。
Oh, I'd never threaten you at all. Get out of here. Listen, I could have you removed for trespassing, just as you were about to have me removed. I didn't threaten you. It wasn't ever a threaten.
哦，我根本不会威胁你。走开。听着，我可以让你因非法侵入而被驱逐，就像你正要让我被驱逐一样。我没有威胁你。那从来没有威胁。
But if you want to threaten me, do it to my face.
但如果你想威胁我，当面做。
I never threatened you, Ken. You seem like you're upset. Good night.
我从来没有威胁过你，肯。你看起来很不安。晚安。
Now, a little crowd gathers, watching them go at it across the basement ballroom.
现在，一小群人聚集在一起，看着他们在地下室宴会厅对质。
Come on, Ken. Look at all the files, baby! Come on, baby, come on!
来吧，肯。看所有的文件，宝贝！来吧，宝贝，来吧！
What about your felony?
你的重罪怎么样？
Yeah, I got a felony for drunk driving. It was years ago. See this right here? That's a negative in the account! There's the $15,000 that came in!
是的，我有一个酒后驾车的重罪。那是几年前的事了。看到这个在这里吗？那是账户里的负数！这里有进来的1.5万美元！
This is the problem with the coup Warren's trying to pull off. It's the problem that was baked into Karamo's version of the party from the start. This group of people all agree on some basic issues-- election fraud, less immigration, no gun control, abortion is murder, don't tell me when to wear a mask, don't tell my children what to read, and the rent is too damn high.
这就是沃伦试图执行的政变的问题。这是从一开始就烘焙进卡拉莫版本党的问题。这群人都在一些基本问题上达成共识——选举舞弊，减少移民，没有枪支管制，堕胎是谋杀，不要告诉我什么时候戴口罩，不要告诉我孩子们读什么，而且租金太高了。
But what's brought them all together running this party is their lack of trust in any kind of political leadership. They are a very suspicious, conspiracy-minded group. And that's how they look at everything, including each other. Of course they can't agree on who the real enemy is of the cause they all actually believe in.
但是什么让他们所有人聚在一起经营这个党是他们对任何一种政治领导的不信任。他们是一个非常多疑、阴谋心态的群体。这就是他们看待一切的方式，包括彼此。当然，他们无法就谁是他们真正相信的事业的真正敌人达成共识。
You lied! You're a liar! You're a liar!
你撒谎了！你是个骗子！你是个骗子！
Right before this story went to air this week, Kristina Karamo finally agreed to an interview. I reached her while she was taking a morning walk. I asked her about her year in power. I told her it seemed like, for all her good intentions, the party's ended up in disarray, broke, and ineffective, without the money it needs to win elections next year.
在这个故事本周播出之前，克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫终于同意接受采访。我在她晨练时联系到了她。我问她掌权的一年。我告诉她，看起来，尽管她有良好的意图，但党最终陷入了混乱，破产，无效，没有明年赢得选举所需的钱。
I will say, I reject your premise that my tenure should be defined by funds. See, that's the problem. Your premise is off. Your premise is that I should be defined by money, because the only people that benefit from the premise you're positing is the political class. The only people that benefit are the elitists. And I was elected to reject that premise.
我会说，我拒绝你认为我的任期应该由资金来定义的前提。看，这就是问题所在。你的前提是错误的。你的前提是我应该由钱来定义，因为从你提出的前提中受益的唯一群体是政治阶级。受益的唯一群体是精英主义者。而我是为了拒绝那个前提而当选的。
This is what it's like to talk to her about this. She wouldn't say what she'd do to get the party out of this mess. She wouldn't even acknowledge that they're in a mess.
这就是谈论这件事的感觉。她不会说她会做些什么让政党摆脱这种困境。她甚至不承认他们处于困境中。
We're not bankrupt. That's not true. So the thing about it is, we are operating at a positive cash flow. So yes, it has-- have I hit the financial goals that I would like? Not at the level I would like, but we are on our way.
我们没有破产。那不是真的。所以关于它的一点是，我们正在以正现金流运营。所以是的，它有——我达到了我想要的财务目标吗？不是我想要的水平，但我们在路上。
Well, that's why I guess I'm asking just for any example. Is there a fundraiser in which you tapped into businesses that had been sitting on the sidelines, like you talked about in your campaign?
好吧，这就是为什么我猜我问的只是任何例子。有没有一个筹款活动，你利用了袖手旁观的企业，就像你在竞选中谈到的那样？
Of course.
当然。
Or something like that?
或者是类似的东西？
Of course.
当然。
Just any specific you can give me?
只是你能给我的任何具体内容？
Yeah, well, for one, yes. But I don't know what specific you're looking for. Because my question is, why are you so dogmatic on the notion of people who want to push the elitist narrative? That's my question. Because I've answered it multiple times.
是的，好吧，首先，是的。但我不知道你在寻找什么具体内容。因为我的问题是，为什么你对推行精英主义叙事的人的概念如此教条？那是我的问题。因为我已经回答过很多次了。
But my question to you, so why are you so aggressive on that notion? I'm not going to go through the nuts and bolts of every person who's given $1 or $10,000 or $20,000 to our administration. I've answered, we're operating at a positive cash flow.
但我的问题是你，所以为什么你对那个概念如此激进？我不会去讨论每一个给我们的政府1美元、1万美元或2万美元的人的细节。我已经回答了，我们正在以正现金流运营。
As of last month, they're bringing in more than they're spending. Not because of any fundraising. They got a payout from a national committee. But they're still deep in debt, and I could not get any specifics from Kristina on how the party would bring in the millions they've always used to run elections for 2024.
截至上个月，他们的收入比支出多。不是因为任何筹款。他们从全国委员会那里得到了款项。但他们仍然欠债深重，而且我无法从克里斯蒂娜那里得到关于该党将如何带来他们一直用来运行2024年选举的数百万美元的具体信息。
She pointed out, again and again, that was the wrong question. They've cut costs. They do have a plan to run a ground game. And once that happens, I can judge how that goes.
她一次又一次指出，那是错误的问题。他们削减了成本。他们确实有一个计划来进行地面游戏。一旦发生，我可以判断它是如何进行的。
Over the last few months, I've watched her circle of supporters get smaller. District chairs have resigned. Members of the budget committee resigned, upset about the finances and that the leadership wouldn't listen to them. For all intents and purposes, the party split in two.
在过去的几个月里，我看着她的支持者圈子变小了。区主席辞职了。预算委员会成员辞职了，对财务感到不安，而且领导层不听他们的。实际上，该党分裂成了两半。
What does it feel like to have all these people, who you guys were on the same team to begin with, calling for your ouster or coming after you, making all these claims? Like, what does it feel like? What's the experience like for you?
让所有这些人，你们起初在同一个团队，呼吁你的罢免或来找你，提出所有这些要求，是什么感觉？就像，是什么感觉？这种体验对你来说是什么样的？
It's betrayal. I don't like it. But when you realize, again, the fact that our country is corrupt and the way it is, because most of the people involved in politics are dishonest. People want to lie and try to demean my character. I mean, so be it. I just keep going.
那是背叛。我不喜欢它。但当你意识到，再次，我们的国家是腐败的事实，以及它是那样，因为大多数参与政治的人是不诚实的。人们想要撒谎并试图贬低我的性格。我的意思是，那又怎样。我只是继续前进。
I was talking to Jon Smith, who was there when this all began. I said, it seems like the year of Kristina Karamo has been a year of failure. The party stopped doing most of the basic normal stuff any political party has to do.
我正在和乔恩·史密斯谈话，他当时就在那里。我说，看起来克里斯蒂娜·卡拉莫的一年是失败的一年。该党停止了任何政治党派必须做的大部分基本正常的事情。
And they're limping as they go into this major presidential election year. And Jon was like, no. Don't write your story like it was a waste. It wasn't a waste. Things are going to continue to be different now.
而且他们进入这个重大总统选举年时步履蹒跚。乔恩就像，不。不要把你的故事写得好像那是一种浪费。那不是浪费。事情现在会继续不同。
We did something. We changed the party. We put a non-billionaire in charge here. This is just a first step. Maybe a misstep, but we're not going to just disappear.
我们做了点什么。我们改变了政党。我们把一个非亿万富翁放在这里负责。这只是第一步。也许是一次失误，但我们不会只是消失。
Zoe Chace.
佐伊·查斯。
["IT LOOKS LIKE THE PARTY IS OVER," BY JOHN ANDERSON]
["看来派对结束了," 作者：约翰·安德森]
Well, our program was edited today by Laura Starecheski, produced by Chris Benderev, with help from James Bennett the Second. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Bethel Habte, Cassie Hawley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alyssa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
好吧，我们的节目今天由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑，由克里斯·本德雷夫制作，并在詹姆斯·贝内特二世的帮助下完成。今天节目的人员包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、贝塞尔·哈布特、凯西·霍利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、赛斯·林德、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、南希·厄普代克和戴安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Isaac Arnsdorf, Kelefa Sanneh, Craig Mauger, Jonathan Oosting, Simon Schuster, Laura Gibbons, Carrie Levine, Jason Roe, Jamie Roe, Zoe Clarke, Colin Jackson, Tyler Scott, Dustin Dwyer, Todd Gillman, Lance Lashaway, Kelly Sackett, Rola Makki, Jonathan Chapman, and Lori Skibo.
我们的常务编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。特别感谢今天的内容：艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫、凯莱法·萨内、克雷格·莫格、乔纳森·奥斯廷、西蒙·舒斯特、劳拉·吉本斯、嘉莉·莱文、杰森·罗、杰米·罗、佐伊·克拉克、科林·杰克逊、泰勒·斯科特、达斯汀·德怀尔、托德·吉尔曼、兰斯·拉沙韦、凯利·萨克特、罗拉·马基、乔纳森·查普曼和洛里·斯基博。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费流媒体我们超过800集的档案。这就是美国生活由PRX，公共广播交易所分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, I invited him to Hanukkah this year. I don't know. I think it's the last time. He lit the candles. He's great at the dreidel game. But he just kept saying the same thing over and over.
你知道，我邀请他参加今年的光明节。我不知道。我想那是最后一次了。他点了蜡烛。他非常擅长陀螺游戏。但他只是不断地重复同一件事。
Do you take Jesus Christ as your Lord and Savior?
你接受耶稣基督作为你的主和救主吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《这就是美国生活》的更多故事。
["IT LOOKS LIKE THE PARTY IS OVER," BY JOHN ANDERSON]
["看来派对结束了," 作者：约翰·安德森]